[Music]
we're gonna have the half-half happiest
Christmas since Bing Crosby tap dance
for Danny
inque
Christmas Eve it it's the one night of
the year when we all act a little nicer
week we we smile a little easier we we
we cheer a little more
[Music]
Rudolph with your nose so bright won't
you guide my sleigh tonight
it will be an honor sir jingle bells
jingle all the way oh what fun it is to
ride on a one-horse open sleigh a very
good
[Music]
get to the bay so desensitized by moving
terrible 2001
you're a twelve hundred year old elf
we're pretty good for your age
thanks but I'm seeing some women rapping
turn around
turn around go back please you forgot
something
yes okay let's do it
let's go get this kicked out of us
finally let out our whole day first
we'll make snow angels for two hours and
then we'll go ice skating and then we'll
eat a whole roll of Tollhouse cookie
dough as fast as we can and then to
finish well snuggle
[Music]
I can't seem to find my toothbrush so I
pick one up when I go out today I lose
and then I'm in good shape
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]